The design of this bottle started in Terre Haute, Indiana in 1915.
At the time, Coca-Cola was being sold at soda fountains,...
...or in a glass bottle called a Hutchinson.
But this simple straight-sided bottle was easy to copy...
...and imitations were flooding the market.
The solution:...
...a national contest for a new bottle that would make Coca-Cola stand out,...
...even if the bottle were broken or you touched it in the dark.
The Root Glass Company got to work on their competition entry,...
...looking up the word "coca" in the encyclopedia...
...and coming across an illustration for a cocoa pod.
The curvy, ridged shape appealed to the team...
...who used it as the basis for their winning design.
The first bottles hit the shelves just a year later...
...with the added touch of the glass being colored German green,...
...later changed to Georgia green in honor of the Coca-Cola company's home state.
Sleek and iconic, this is the design that's flaunted its curves...
...to become the trademark of the most popular drink in the world.